It's often culturally and socially reinforced...
...that there's something wrong or shameful about feeling sad.
We tend to have this cultural bias towards valuing positive thinking.
But studies have shown that those who try and suppress negative thoughts...
...actually experience more of them,...
...which can lead to overeating and stronger stress responses.
Inside Out shows us that our negative emotions can guide our rational thinking.
Sadness is a trigger for seeking comfort and bonding.
We're often tough on sadness, but it's important to our understanding of who we are.
In his 1621 work "Anatomy of Melancholy",...
...Robert Burton wrote, in experiencing melancholy, "increaseth sorrow, increaseth wisdom."
Even those emotions that we consider as negative can help guide us to good, rational decisions.
So, even if you're riding down or inside out the emotional roller coaster,...
...remember that your positive and negative emotions can and do team up.
There's always an upside.